افادت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن تقييم اوليا
للجيش الامريكي ان المسيره التي قتلت
ثلاثه جنود امريكيين في قاعده بالاردن لم
يرصد اقترابها من القاعده ولم يكن هناك
نظام دفاع جوي قادر على اسقاطها ونقلت
الصحيفه عن مسؤول دفاعي امريكي مطلع على
التقيييم قوله ان المسيره ربما لم تكتشف
بسبب مسارها المنخفض كما ان القاعده في
الاردن لم تكن مجهزه بالاسلحه التي يمكن
ان تصد اخطارا جويه كال المسيرات معتمده
بدلا من ذلك على انظمه الحروب الالكترونيه
المصممه لتعطيلها وكشف مسؤولون دفاعيون
امريكيون للصحيفه ان المسيره حلقتها على
علو منخفض حتى لا تكشف وخلصت واشنطن بوست
الى ان النتائج الاوليه تقوض التاكيدات
السابقه بان الدفاعات الجويه الامريكيه
اخطات في اعتبار المسايره امريكيه عائده
الى القاعده وتضيف الصحيفه ان التقييم
يثير تساؤلات بشان قدره البنتاجون على
مواكبه الاخطار المحدقه بالقوات الامريكيه
المنتشره في
المنطقه